Mars the Red Planet
made from rock iron fable and meth since
the ancients named it for the God of War
it has had a unique hold over the human
imagination
even before humans set foot on the moon
it was seen as the next step but why
there are similarities between Mars and
Earth it has a 24 hour day and four
seasons though it's air is too thin to
breathe and its surface too cold for
unsheltered life it is far more
astronaut friendly than any of the other
planets it has huge canyons and vast
volcanoes its riverbeds Delta's and
dried lakes speak of a past more watery
than its arid present yet although it is
scarce in briny there is still some
liquid water on Mars today and water is
key to life
the possibility that Mars once had life
or might just possibly still have it
today is one of the reasons more space
probes have been sent there than to any
other planet
NASA's insight probe which landed in
November is the latest and Europe's
ExoMars Rover will arrive next year NASA
talks of sending humans to Mars on a new
spacecraft within the next two decades
Elon Musk's space technology company
SpaceX has plans as early as 2024
such missions with crews would be among
the biggest technical challenges humans
have ever undertaken the journey can
only be made when the planets are
properly aligned that only occurs
roughly every 26 months but even then it
takes around nine months to travel from
one planet to the other
[Music]
the challenge of a life-support system
that can operate for years without
resupply is daunting the cost will be
high
and the hurdles amounts
but the challenge is so exciting it
seems certain that some will try it and
quite likely that some will die trying
[Music]
coming up next Thursday the hunt for
oceans in space